Dear fellow scholars. This is two minute papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér. Let's ask.
To jump into the pool at the same time on three, two,
one go. And then this happens.
And if we slow things down,
like we would slow down an action sequence in a movie. Look,
this is one and then two, and then three,
not even close to being in the same time we see that this footage is
completely unsalvageable. And please note the smile at the end of the video.
I'll tell you in a moment why, imagine that after a little training,
the little chaps were able to jump into the pool at the same time.
Congratulations, but wait a second. Look,
the smile is the same. As in the previous footage,
this is not a different video. This is the same video as before,
but it has been three timed to seem as if the jumps happened at the same
time. Absolutely amazing. And how about this footage?
They move in tandem totally in tandem, right?
Except that this was the original footage, which is a complete mess.
And now with this technique, it could be re timed as if this happened,
incredible work. So what is this wizardry?
This is a new learning based technique that can pull off nice tricks like this,
and it can deal with cases that would otherwise be extremely challenging to read
time by hand, to find out why let's have a look at this footage.
Got it. And now let's try to pretend that this meeting never happened.
Now, first, to be able to do this,
we have to be able to recognize the test subjects of the video.
This method performs pose estimation. These are the skeletons that you see here,
nothing new here. This can be done with off the shelf components. However,
that is not nearly enough to remove or a time them we need to do more.
Why is that? Well, look,
mirror reflections and shadows.
If we will only be able to remove the person,
these secondary effects would give the trick away in a second to address this
issue.
One of the key contributions of this new AI based technique is that it is able
to find these mirror reflections, shadows, and even more,
which can be defined as motions that correlate with a test subject or in
other words, things that move together with the humans.
And if we have all of these puzzle pieces,
we can use a newer render to remove people or even adjust the
timing of these videos.
And now hold onto your papers because it is not at all limited to shadows
and mirror reflections. Remember this example here,
the algorithm recognizes that these people cause deformations in the,
and is able to line them up together.
Note that we need some intense and variable time warping to make this
happen. And as an additional bonus photo bombing,
cumin has been removed from the footage. Then you're a renderer.
This work is from the pigs to pigs paper from only three years ago.
And now with some ingenious improvements,
it can be elevated to a whole new level,
huge congratulations to the authors for this incredible achievement and all of
this can be done in an interactive app that is able to quickly preview the
results for us. What a time to be alive.
What you see here is a report of this exact paper we have talked about,
which was made by weights and biases. I put a link to it in the description,
make sure to have the look. I think it helps you understand this paper better.
During my PhD studies, I trained a ton of neural networks,
which were used in our experiments. However, over time,
there was just too much data in our repositories.
And what I am looking for is not data, but insight.
And that's exactly how weights and biases helps you by organizing your
experiments. It is used by more than 200 companies and research institutions,
including open AI Toyota research GitHub and more,
and get this weights and biases is free for all individuals academics
and open source projects. Make sure to visit them through
wmb.com/papers, or just click the link in the video description.
And you can get the freedom or today our thanks to weights and biases for their
longstanding support and for helping us make better videos for you.
Thanks for watching and for your generous support. And I'll see you next time.